(intriguing music)
- [Narrator] House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
can't seem to catch a break.
- [Reporter] 15 rounds of voting
before McCarthy was able to
take control of the gavel.
- Political battle over
raising the debt ceiling.
- [Reporter] Chaos in Congress
as the government lurches
towards a possible shutdown.
- [Narrator] McCarthy
has a razor-thin majority
in the GOP-led House
and is facing a looming
partial government shutdown
that could cost him the gavel.
- Many Republicans think
he's doing the best
that anyone could do,
but you have a number of
very hard-line Republicans
who either want him out
or want him to do exactly what they say,
and it's gonna be really hard
to satisfy both of those wings
with such a small majority.
- [Narrator] Here's a
look at the power struggle
amongst House Republicans
that is affecting McCarthy's
control over his own party
and how that could lead
to a government shutdown.
(gentle music)
House lawmakers are scrambling to pass
a short-term spending
bill by September 30th,
the end of the fiscal year,
to avoid a partial government shutdown.
The only problem,
the majority of House
Republicans can't seem to agree
on what goes in that bill.
A faction of Republicans
is threatening not to pass legislation
if McCarthy doesn't include their demands
in any funding deal.
- It's a group of Republicans
who are willing to basically
undercut the party's
legislation to make a point
and to try to, you know,
hold out for a better deal.
- [Narrator] This group of lawmakers
all agree on the need to do one thing:
cut government spending.
But some in the group
are also making other disparate demands,
like ending aid to Ukraine and
tightening border security.
Some are also threatening to oust McCarthy
if he doesn't meet their demands.
- Members of the Freedom Caucus
are very, you know, hard line,
the members who want to sharply
cut government spending.
But then there's other
folks like Matt Gaetz
who's not a member of the Freedom Caucus
but is a very, very
outspoken critic of McCarthy.
He's got a whole list of demands
and things he wants McCarthy to do,
but at the end of the day,
he really just doesn't
want McCarthy as speaker.
- The path forward for the
House of Representatives
is to either bring you into
immediate total compliance
or remove you pursuant to a
motion to vacate the chair.
- [Narrator] This isn't the first time
McCarthy has gone head to head with Gaetz
and other hard-line House Republicans.
- A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker has not been elected.
- [Narrator] Back in January,
McCarthy struggled to obtain
the majority of votes needed
to become speaker,
enduring 15 rounds of voting
before he won the seat.
(lawmakers applauding and cheering)
Gaetz and several other
Republicans led that opposition,
and to win them over, McCarthy
made several concessions,
like promising deep spending cuts.
- The problem is that every
time he gets one thing done,
he makes promises to some
members about doing future things
to help them out or to win them over,
and at some point all those
promises start to come due.
(lawmakers applauding)
- [Narrator] McCarthy's plight
is an unfamiliar territory.
- John Boehner.
- [Narrator] Speaker John
Boehner resigned in 2015
after being squeezed by clashing factions
within his own party
over spending cuts needed to
avoid a government shutdown.
- Republican House Speakers
have a long history
of having a lot of dissidents
who nip at their heels
for years and years
and try to push them on issues including,
you know, deficits, debts, and spending.
What is new is that his
majority is so small
that he cannot just ignore people.
He has to actually deal with them
in order to get legislation passed.
Past speakers could probably
ignore 10 or 15 or 20 members
and still get bills over the finish line,
McCarthy cannot.
- [Narrator] To pass the
short-term spending bill,
McCarthy can't afford to
lose more than four votes
without help from Democrats.
- Let's make sure the
government stays open
while we finish doing our job,
passing all the individual
bills and getting this stuff.
- McCarthy's, you know, is
a very personable leader.
He likes having relationships.
He's not so much a policy guy,
so it really is a matter
of managing his caucus,
getting a bill they can pass.
- [Narrator] The
Republican-controlled House
and the Democrat-controlled Senate
will also have to negotiate a
full year spending agreement.
- You know I'm not a fan
of government shutdowns.
I've seen a few of them over the years.
They never have produced a policy change,
and they've always been
a loser for Republicans.
- [Narrator] Shut down or not,
the slim majority and political
infighting in the House
aren't going to go away for McCarthy.
- There's still the looming question
of "If not McCarthy, then who?"
His number two, Steve Scalise,
is undergoing cancer treatments.
There's other Republicans
who could theoretically leave the caucus,
but it's not clear that any of them
would be in a better position to do it.
For McCarthy, it's just another example
of where he's in this crazy situation
and looking for a Houdini-like
trick to wiggle his way out,
and it's just not clear
how he's gonna do that.
(graceful piano music)